I possess the most advanced
entertainment algorithm in the world and
it produces near perfect products did he
wink with the red
light well the internet will happily
oblige with that debate my friends
welcome back to New rockstars the
She-Hulk finale brings an end to one era
of the MCU as the final multi-episode
MCU streaming series on Disney plus of
phase four black panther what kind of
forever is coming to theaters November
11th in the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special will be another Marvel
Studios special presentation coming at
the end of this year but starting in
2023 Phase 5 will begin with quantumania
and secret Invasion so today we are
going to assess the state of MCU phase 4
streaming series with our individual
rankings and we can all agree that
whatever your thoughts are in this
current transition period we need to
talk about gun Kevin
this is inside Marvel new Rockstar's
weekly Marvel reaction show I'm Eric
Boss with me today is Jessica Clemens
and Mt and we are terrified to rank
these titles yo like people haven't been
asking me to rank these MCU titles for
like for months now I was like yo empty
like what's your ranking I'm just like
know what I don't really like ranking
them well today's the day today's the
day we're gonna we're gonna rank these
these we've done this on the break room
with like the phase four movies and the
situation is I rank mine based off what
I enjoy and I still will start a circus
amongst people and so if you guys if you
guys put it in more Niche terms and
you're like okay well which ones do you
think is cinematically this or the
writing's best or better for the MCU I
can rank those but this is what I like
this is what I like this is true there
is no wrong answer yes sir there is no
wrong answer but there's also no right
answer uh because everyone's gonna come
after us anyway and you know what Jess I
think what you say uh your way of
ranking things it's a smarter way to do
it I just do it based off of how I'm
feeling when we hit play on this
recording because I'm like my opinion my
ranking is constantly changing if we
were to do another one of these episodes
next week I would probably change the
ranking so really this is just a
snapshot for how we're feeling in the
wake of
which I think is a fair time to snap a
Polaroid of us right now because that
that really is how uh you're feeling you
know when we walked out of the theater
for Thor love and thunder I was feeling
one way but like months later I'm like
oh I don't know if that stayed with me I
said it was my favorite thing to ever
hit the MCU and then after I listened to
a lot of people I was
like
high off watching it you know not not
like like the high of like after you
leave a theater and you're like oh that
was great and it was the most recent MCU
movie we saw and I cried and then I have
to come out and be like it's not my
number one like yeah it's my number one
but yeah now it's not I think there's
you got distressed Zeus flicks too hard
I think we all did hey but you know what
I think there is a legitimacy to raiding
a movie that way as you walk out of a
theater might be the most sacred time in
a movie going experience when you're
supposed to calibrate your feelings on
it when you come out in that theater
Lobby you get the smell of the popcorn
for the next batch of people going into
the theater and you're talking with your
friends outside the theater in the lobby
for me as a as a movie lover that is the
most precious time that those are the
moments I remember the most like after
going to see like The Dark Knight or
Inception uh or other movies not
directed by Christopher Nolan like when
I'm in the parking lot with my friends
or we're going to Steak and Shake
afterwards and we're all like talking
about what we like liked what we didn't
like that's that's when you're supposed
to uh fortify or or cement capture in
stone exactly how you felt about a movie
and then sometime later in your life
when you watch it with like a loved one
or with your family then your feelings
about it change but I think it's
important to capture that moment right
after seeing a movie and it's not wrong
for having for feeling a high or a buzz
because that's what the filmmaker is
designing these movies to make us feel
just rant over I'm personally yelling at
you both no no dude it's totally fine
personally after I walk out of the
theater I like to adopt the personality
of the main character as I'm walking I
like that because that's the time uh to
do that that feeling where you walk out
of the theater and you're just like you
know what I am Leonardo DiCaprio in an
Inception I will uh shoot someone in my
dreams for the season I was like yeah
you see the Batman and you're like you
know what I should fight crime on a
scale of what I think is bad and good
exactly after I watched the Batman I was
like maybe something is in the way maybe
I love you both so much I can't wait to
um destroy our professional reputations
by ranking these titles
um so let's just dive into it um so MCU
phase four rankings we're limiting just
the Disney Plus shows now we don't we
didn't know what the startup phase for
when exactly phase four began or when it
would end but at Comic-Con last summer
Kevin feige firmly drew the boundary
lines by confirming that phase four
would end with black panther wakanda
forever in November and phase five would
begin with Ant-Man the wasp quantumania
in February now that means She-Hulk was
the final Disney plus MCU streaming
series of phase four and again we still
have the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special coming this year but like
werewolf by night that will be a one-off
special presentation it is MCU Cannon
just not the same kind of multi-chapter
narrative that seriously aims to move
the ball forward in meaningful ways
though I guess you could argue not all
these multi-episode series have done
that but I think just the intent by uh
Marvel Studios by how they're presenting
these stories to us I think we should we
should rate these multi-episode stories
on a different basis so that leaves us
Eight titles that we're going to be
looking at today one division the Falcon
the Winter Soldier Loki what if Hawkeye
Moon Knight Ms Marvel and She-Hulk for
now we're gonna leave out the movies
we're gonna leave out werewolf by night
we're gonna leave out I am Groot but we
will add those in later in different
ways in this episode so
um we're gonna go one by one we're gonna
start at the bottom of our rankings
sorry okay sorry we're gonna
we're gonna talk about why they didn't
work for us but that doesn't mean that
they're horrible because we're just
ranking them against each other I think
we can all agree that all eight of these
titles had their moments and had things
that are worth praise but some that are
also worth criticism so uh let's talk
about what do we think what phase four
MCU series do we think struggle the most
at the bottom of our list number eight
who wants to go first I can go first I
don't think it struggled but I do think
because of the pandemic it did put a
kind of bad hold on this one I put
Falcon in the Winter Soldier okay me as
well I did I did as well so we all agree
[Music]
I remember during it they were like I
know there was a lot of stuff with the
the the what the person got sick from
and I know they took a lot of stuff out
because it was reminiscent of kovid and
I remember being like it does suck the
timing in which this does come out but
it did take a lot out of the storyline
for the flag Smashers and their families
and I was like I'm really interested so
I just feel like that was the one bump
for me but it doesn't make it a bad
thing I just I just it genuinely for me
that's how I felt at least the mama yeah
the Cornerstone of the MC very fun
character love Baron Zemo in it Baron
Zemo was so cool yeah absolutely I agree
I think a lot of the things that were
introduced in this series I genuinely
love and I can't wait to see again in
the MCU especially introducing uh Sam
Wilson as Captain America I think it's
great I like Joaquin Torres
um and I can't wait to see Bucky again
in Thunderbolts I can't wait to see Zemo
again my issues with it is if this were
just a series about Sam Wilson coming to
terms with his uh his legacy of carrying
the shield
um talking to The Bradley family and get
to know them and the whole racist
history of of the super soldier program
I think that's a fascinating series my
issue with this is that they also made
this a flag Smasher series and I don't
think they knew uh halfway through that
production exactly what they wanted to
say with the flag Smashers and it was a
bit of a this mess I think some of it
was like uh re-editing from from covid
parallels uh I think some of it also was
just like a misfire with the character
of a John Walker of Johnny Manny's is
empty as coined him I just think like
that character was meant to be a villain
and the way that they redeemed him in
the final episode just really left a bad
taste in my mouth like he was uh quoting
Abraham Lincoln and giving each other
pats on the shoulder helping each other
out I'm like no this character is a
murderer and we shouldn't be feeling
good about him right now also I just
think that the whole twist with the
power broker is Sharon Carter was just
such a a misfire with the character
Sharon card I think she was so
interesting coming out of Civil War and
and Winter Soldier and now coming into
this show where she we have to imagine
this weird off-screen storyline where
she Rose to this like criminal
mastermind of madraport I just thought
was like the most the least interesting
version of the power broker character
and I'm just not excited to see Power
broker again in the MCU this is just me
but again all the stuff I love seeing
Bucky I love seeing Sam Wilson I just
think like the fact that the first
episode of that series they are not
together at all and they are the titular
Duo and then for like one sixth of the
story they're not hanging out or like I
feel like what was promised to me was
like this cool buddy action comedy and
we got so little of that in this show
overall yeah I no I I um I definitely
did like Falcon the Winter Soldier like
it was a really great show
um and like you're right like I really
would have appreciated like the duo like
assembling pretty early on and like you
know just having that buddy cop action
and I definitely agree that the flag
Smashers were not handled right at all
the flag smashes were underutilized and
like I I feel like they had the
opportunity I feel like what in what
they really wanted to do with um the
show was sort of show how the super
soldier serum can make
what is going on inside even worse and
like so like you know Johnny mayonnaise
was already dealing with you know his
own PTSD and the super soldier serum
made it worse and it Amplified his um is
his mental illness and I think in the
same with um with Carly and Elvis the
flex matches and um I feel like that's
what they were trying to go for but like
they didn't really do a great job with
um sort of like making that clear but
like yeah I sort of just think it just
it was sort of a mess but like it was a
great show I really enjoyed watching it
I enjoyed like you know reviewing it
like it I had a really great time with
it and I love seeing uh Sam Wilson
appear as Captain America for the first
time goosebumps every time
um it's just it's so cool um especially
as a black person just like yo this is
this is happening this is actually yeah
it's sad as a black person but it also
as our last
I know I feel like I genuinely was like
but that's also the thing is like I
wanted a lot more and I didn't right
yeah so I mean I think one of the the
best phase four story lines overall was
just Sam Wilson's Journey with the
Bradley family and with Isaiah Bradley I
think that's one of the most daring one
of the boldest one of the most
fascinating storylines and I wish that
could have just been the show like just
that 100 you know would have been would
have been at least my top three you know
um but I think like yeah the issue with
the flag Smashers is among many things
even looking back on it
I I still struggle to remember were they
people who were blipped but then like
blipped back into reality where they
didn't have a home anymore or no they
weren't they were people who survived
the blip but then were displaced by that
and the fact that we didn't see that at
all especially coming on the other side
of a lot of these Disney plus titles
where we got to see that for uh Elena
Bulova
um and like the people that were
disheveled by that return like the fact
that we just didn't see that just felt
like such like a half-baked uh
motivation for those characters right I
def yeah I feel like we definitely
should like see the scene of just like
people being like all right leave we're
we're moving into a different area like
people you know being affected by that
and like yeah that would have really
gone a long way for sure yeah for that
series instead we just got these weird
shots of like a a refugee camp where
where kids are playing soccer and then
we hear this voiceover of like
characters who are strategizing we don't
see anyone talking on screen anymore
like what the hell is going on right now
uh it was a mess all right let's move on
to our number seven picks uh Okay who
wants to go first for their number seven
um I can go so I can
um break someone's heart in this room a
little quicker
um okay okay number seven is Hawkeye
number seven is Hawkeye okay
it's number seven for
eign
let's quickly say why Jessica and I
thought I thought it was uh I genuinely
think it was a fine show I love all the
characters in it I think it was fine
um I just think the other shows compared
to it didn't hold up for me
um I needed to like Clint a lot more in
order I liked Haley I like Kate Bishop
way more than Clint I was like I don't
think I like Clint enough I don't like
Clint enough and I need someone to give
me more reason to love Clint I just
don't think I got enough and I felt more
from Kate Bishop I felt way more for
Kate Bishop I thought um this series
really had some great characters in it I
love the introduction of Kate bishop and
the inclusion of um of uh yolina bolova
I love Maya Lopez I can't wait to see
Echo
um I just think for me it's very
important that these series stick the
landing and when in the final two
episodes they just completely face plant
and I think in my opinion Hawkeye
totally did face plant at the end that
finale episode is really poorly edited
episode of TV and I think when they
introduce Kingpin is that the Atlanta
Bulova crime no the Elena Bulova episode
was great that was right in the middle
I'm talking about where they finally
reveal that Kingpin like episode 5 had
Kingpin showed on a freaking cell phone
like a really poorly that's the way you
introduce Kingpin uh in this part of the
MCU and then from there we go into this
episode where it's like he's the
character we have no idea really where
he's coming from they cut so many scenes
with Kingpin with uh with Eleanor Bishop
uh we don't really know if he's super
powered or not and it's just the
character of Kazi uh these scenes where
Kazi is fighting Echo are just such a
mess uh like we don't really know how
we're supposed to feel with these
characters there's so many plot lines
that were just like wait really that's
what it culminates in uh like uh there's
like an owl that comes down and and
Dooms two of the track suits to the most
horrific death I think I've seen in the
MCU including Multiverse of Madness I
don't know I really really just like so
many of the early episodes I love the
holiday Vibes I love the chase scene the
the Pim Arrow so many high water marks
for me and Hawkeye again I don't hate it
that much it's just so many all these
others
I would have never guessed that from
them
you remind me a lot of things that I
genuinely forgot about like I did for
which is horrible I forgot we were
introduced to uh Wilson Fisk this way
that we were
yeah on a cell phone we were and we were
all so mad
I forgot about that completely because
it was in Christmas it was so long ago
almost a full year oh my God I
completely forgot about that yeah that's
true that's true but you know what I
love the Christmas Vibes of this show I
I've tried when I think back on it I
really try to remember how much I love
those first four episodes how much I
loved Maya's introduction episode three
her and her karate class as a kid I
really really enjoyed all that
um empty you'll have your chance to
defend your Hawkeye position later but
what was your number I'm so excited to
hear what your seven is I'm so excited
and if it hurts my feelings I'm gonna
wind up it's
I struggled with this I struggled with
this even though I really enjoyed this
show this is like even though like you
know this these are the bottom of our
list this by no means means that we
think that they sucked it's just like
you know
um it is uh the Mr Bean uh season one uh
very low on my just kidding I love Mr
Bean
um no Miss Marvel for me is my name okay
okay I I though I really had a great
time with the show and like it was just
you know I loved
hanging out with kamala's family and
hanging out with her friends and like
the editing of the first few episodes
was phenomenal like I just I love that
show so much
um but I just feel like the villains
were not really all that compelling for
me and like that whole I'll never forget
the the dodc Escape scene where they
just sort of Justice just walked in the
tunnel stepped up the stairs yeah like
right near the exit and like it was just
like whoa like really and like I I
wanted to see more of the clandestines
um Dimension and like how they lived and
like they kept talking about yeah like
we live this way and like a few things
like like show us
what your universe is like because it
seems like you guys are just like energy
beings so like show us the stakes show
us what it would look like if you guys
um if the the faults or um the crack or
whatever the
um
the veil cracked yes
um the veil cracked and like what would
our universe look like and like what are
the and like we didn't really get that
and like I I liked how they tied
um the crack in the veil with like
Kamala Khan's symbol and like you know
that's sort of what that means and like
I I like that Kamala is has her roots in
in this interdimensionals like uh
species or or beings
um but like I just feel like you know
having that that final battle with
Cam'ron it was nice symbolism but like
it just didn't really do it for me like
the whole
I just I I wish that her her origin
story that was a little bit more like oh
[ __ ] like what like these villains are
really compelling and like we didn't
really get that and like there's plenty
of room for that in the future obviously
but like
um I I just wanted more information
other than that like the show was great
and like I I loved Amanda's performance
as this Marvel and uh you bring up a lot
of good points Mt and you're just like
you know you're reminding me of a lot of
issues I had in the middle of that
season of watching Ms Marvel yeah a lot
of the stuff with the clandestines in
the veil is just really really
underdeveloped and we don't really get
to explore it nearly enough it seems
like they were trying to fit a lot in
that series and yeah it definitely did
lose especially at that wedding fight
where all their powers were supposed to
be like this is supposed to be a big
spectacle of super powered people
fighting when they got arrested and put
in the dodc and they're able to break
out it makes no sense I think everything
with the clandestines is a bit of a mess
to me they were the flag Smashers of Ms
Marvel yeah it's just like they didn't
need to be part of the show the flag
Smashers didn't need to be Falcon Winter
Soldier the uh and the clandestines did
not to be need to be a Ms Marvel in my
opinion that was just me yeah I feel
like there's I feel like they could have
been in those shows but they could have
just been handled a little bit better
um yeah but I don't know it is what it
is my it's all good let's actually say
my six and five are kind of
interchangeable I don't want to jump
ship okay I don't want to jump and tell
you my fifth but they are
interchangeable and I just kind of want
to say that before I say what my number
six is okay okay I put my number six as
She-Hulk
okay yes so far you and I are exactly
the same She-Hulk is my number six as
well did you look at my list did you
hack into my computer I think our number
five is this Jess works for the Pentagon
confirmed wow wow I know I know my
number two at number one are different
though I know our number two are number
one are different I can guarantee okay I
was gonna say let's just quickly let's
do the same thing and uh and assess why
Jess and I I could say for me
um She-Hulk was originally lower on my
list I think I had it lower than Hawkeye
I don't know if I had it lower than
Falcon Winter Soldier but I think uh
She-Hulk really saved itself with its
final two episodes I very much enjoyed
the Daredevil episode and I really
really did love this finale I think it's
exactly what I wanted from She-Hulk even
though even though She-Hulk left me a
lot of unanswered questions I think uh
those that middle stretch of episodes
really really did want us to care about
the Intelligentsia uh wanted us to care
about Titania at several points
um and I think it really did lose its
way I think this is a result of a
post-production structuring of the
season is the reason why we are left
with the feeling a little wandering in
the middle of the season I really did
like this emotional confession from Jen
when she was up at this Ranch I like
this character beat from her but I just
think in general this season really
would have benefited from more
structural breaking the fourth wall not
just the character talking to the
audience but like video glitches things
like that just to kind of let us know
that this is all the presented
simulation of a robotic Mastermind
um but uh overall I I very much enjoyed
the introduction of Jen Walters I just
think like the other two titles at the
bottom of my list they just introduced
too much on this show and didn't really
seem to have a firm grasp on what story
they wanted to tell and I think with and
this is just my opinion I think uh if
you're gonna have a character break the
fourth wall and talk to talk to the
audience you have to know exactly who
that audience is and I think that
She-Hulk writers are all very very
talented people I can't wait to see what
they do next but I think they were
writing this show just a bit too much
for their friends on Twitter who are
part of the LA comedy scene who watch
episodes of Marvel shows in between of
episodes of succession in Euphoria and
not people who religiously watch every
Disney plus Marvel show because I think
if you knew the audience who was
watching the Disney plus Marvel shows
you would have just had a couple
different things
there were a lot of jokes in there where
I was like I was like this is perfect I
love this but then when I would do my
breakdown and uh my friends would do
their breakdowns and I'd watch theirs
and I was like no that's not correct and
then I was like they're not in La doing
comedy at UCB like I did and like there
was lines where I was like Cody you
strictly put in like a nod to La like
comedy scene and I don't think anyone
else would get that I didn't think about
that but that is true I put Shield
against my number six because I love
She-Hulk I'm gonna say that first I love
She-Hulk I did the breakdowns I read the
comics I love She-Hulk Richard great
show but it was a show that I don't
think the information I took from that
show isn't gonna alter too much of the
MCU for me and when I say that it's like
Hawkeye and the Falcon Winter Soldier
had a lot of information we're getting
the Thunderbolts next with these people
and it's like She-Hulk the show was
supposed to be about She-Hulk and the
thing that's going further in the MCU is
Scar and Hulk so I didn't really I was
like I the show's about She-Hulk and
then the thing that we're gonna really
be talking about is Scar and Hulk we're
gonna talk about Daredevil too but
Daredevil's also gonna get his own
series and be an echo so it's like it
doesn't he didn't need to be in She-Hulk
to be a bigger person he's gonna get his
own show and he's gonna be an echo so
it's like he's fine he's fine when in
and not in Shield but like I was like
there's a lot of stuff in here that
I was like this is for me as a 30 year
old woman not for me as like a Marvel
fan
which I think is okay um and I just um a
lot of the counter argument to that Jess
I've heard is like well not everything
has to be for everyone sometimes and I
to that I say yeah I think there are
some shows that um are are trying to
prioritize one audience over another I
think that's totally fine but I would
make that same argument for some other
titles on the list I would make I don't
think the show Euphoria was written for
me no but I still very much enjoyed it
for you I think that's an A plus episode
I think it's an A plus Tv show uh I
think if you do it right a show can
still Elevate and give representation to
a different uh type of character in a
different storyline while still inviting
an audience who that isn't necessarily
for and to enjoying it and I don't think
She-Hulk did that well enough to be fair
uh to go along with my thing my number
one is kind of in the same book and
we'll get into it in a second uh my
number one cool
um but let's let's keep moving on to Mt
what's your number six
my number six is
um Hawkeye okay so you put Hawkeye and
then Miss Marvel oh there's a writing
right okay okay and like you know like I
struggled with this one because like you
know I really enjoyed both these series
again but like I really just loved how
Hawkeye had like a really good
Christmasy feel well also introducing
Kate Bishop in a really dope way and
like you know I I've been wanting Kate
Bishop in the MCU for forever
um and like after reading um like the
Matt fraction run like of Hawkeye which
is like the the number one run I'm just
like bro hearing that they were gonna
adapt that I was like yo let's go like
this it's like literally so much fun
it's such a fun run
um and they did a great job with
adapting it
um but like the reason why it's so low
for me is because
um you know like they the villains
weren't all that
um interesting and I just felt like the
I mean I like the track suit so those
are really fun but like I didn't really
know what they were doing with the watch
and like they didn't really know they
didn't really expel that out and like
why they were going after it and I'm
sure that's going to be really important
later on in the MCU but like I don't
know you know the Revelation that like
you know she's she's Mockingbird
apparently in the MCU
um is is I mean it's not really
confusing for us because like we've sort
of like assumed that the Agents of
Shield universe is not
um 616 and it's like an adjacent
neighboring universe but um a lot of
people seeing that were just like whoa
what happened to
the of the Mockingbird from ages of
Shield
um so like I don't know I just feel like
they should they could have just
explained that more and why that was a
bigger deal and like you know again like
you guys said the Wilson the Wilson Fisk
reveal
um though like I'm I feel like it was
edited like um oddly because they were
trying to keep it a secret
um because like I was like uh that's all
I was thinking when I was watching that
episode I was like all right they're
probably in the secluded room because
like if they were like outside like
everyone would know like all of his
scenes were just like hidden and like
um so I don't know I feel like that
could have been a factor and also a
coven but anyway yeah that's my that's
my number six I think you bring a lot of
good points empty I I love all three of
our lists I mean Jess obviously you and
I have the same list but I like how you
have different reasons why you're
placing things in Mt you are currently
the the Rogue one of the bunch here but
uh I can't argue I cannot debate uh any
of your points here I think you are
completely right in the way you're
rankings let's move on to number five
now you said you're number five
I will start with my number five my
number five is what if you were gonna do
that I knew you were gonna do that I
knew you know why I knew you were gonna
do that because my number five was what
if but last minute before we jumped in
this I changed it I changed it I oh my
God
Miss Marvel's my number five I changed
Miss War I changed my number five to
Miss Marvel so mine's different than
yours I changed it right before this
meeting I kid you not because I thought
about it I thought about it I want to
hear why you chose what if though
because I thought I was gonna but what
if what if was higher in uh in my list
as I was like going through the MCU
phase four titles I very very much enjoy
what if and I think the doctor strange
episode of what if is like by itself
like a top five uh storyline and all the
MCU subplots in this phase for sure I
think just uh the series overall was
just a little too uneven the episodes
were just kind of a grab bag some
episodes were just so so good I love the
Black Panther Guardians of the Galaxy
episode I I like the Peggy Carter intro
I thought that was really fun
um I think the Thor episode is just
completely forgettable and just
ridiculous
um and um I would very much enjoy the
The Twist uh and what if to have uh
because here's what I really love about
what if it might be maybe it deserves to
be higher on my list but I just think
like what it does really well is AC
Bradley just understood
um from a outside bird's eye view Vision
what they wanted this series to be and I
think it's just artfully really really
well done I think tonally it's a little
mismatched I really do love how all the
characters come together at the end to
form the Guardians of the Multiverse uh
to fight
um uh Ultron Infinity I think um the the
finale episodes mostly stick the ending
uh mostly stick the ending we just have
this weird kind of place where like
characters get leveled up way too fast
where we can't even understand what
their power uh Stakes are anymore it
almost feels like me on the playground
in third grade being like well I have a
shield that can beat your sword well I
have a sword that also has a gun
attached to it well I'm also a guy that
can oversee all robots well I'm also a
robot that can oversee all gods it's
kind of like whoa whoa whoa whoa okay
what is anything anymore and uh so it
just kind of seemed like it it just kind
of blew everything up a little too fast
for me but I say this as someone who
very much loved one we're in the middle
stage here I don't want to curtain too
much I loved what I think that's why
what if was my number five what if was
my number five but I
and like you said that doctor strange
episode took me by storm dude I oh
art like perfect oh my God poetic Cinema
like it was so good I I remember being
like I sat there and just watched my
screen after that episode ended and I
loved the I loved the t'challa episode I
thought it was really sweet just also
just again the opinions of everyone
else's views uh in that episode I just I
think I just genuinely like what if
because it reminds me of us it's it's
what we do it's like it's like yeah
maybe it won't fit on their timeline but
we could make a series that does fit on
the timeline what you're saying is
logical so it's like we could make what
if like it I I just love what if okay by
the way number five is Miss Marvel for
me because
I I um I loved Ms Marvel I read the
comics and I love the comics I think
they did a really good job I know a lot
of people that's a lot of people's
actual like frustration with Marvel
they're like it's not like the comics
and I was like I think they did a pretty
good job
um I like the comics I like the show and
um it was for me I put Miss Marvel in
another show really high because I
learned from it I went to a school in
the Pacific Northwest where they didn't
get into the partition of India at all
and so all of the stuff I learned about
like a East Coast Pakistani American
family I genuinely had to start like
looking into myself after watching Miss
Marvel and during Miss Marvel because I
didn't know a lot about that culture so
I genuinely put Miss Marvel's number
five because I was like I learned a lot
about it culturally and I'm really
excited to see this character and her
family and also is there another
character in the MCU yet that's like a
child that literally just came to her
parents and they were like we're cool
it's fine we know you're a superhero
that's fine like I mean maybe Peter
Parker a little bit oh yeah a little bit
yeah you're right she died either way
but
but yeah I like her family and I like
the idea of just getting the point of
view of a family that's genuinely like
yeah you are a hero you're a hero
without powers and you're a hero with
powers and the mom being okay because I
think a lot of us have those moms that
are kind of helicopter moms that are
always looking out just to make sure
we're safe oh yeah I know like I
identified a lot with a Kamala situation
because like I I have a Haitian mom and
uh like who's very religious and she
would not let me do anything anything so
I felt I fell for that I felt I felt Mt
what is your number five I'm excited
what is it my number five gang is
She-Hulk okay I use well you love him
I love she all like she all because
literally uh tied for my number one
favorite MCU character right now with um
vision and Steve Rogers I just love like
how she can like break the fourth wall
but also
just how I don't know just she's just
personable and she's real and Tatiana
maslani it's just the perfect the
perfect woman for this role I I didn't
know that she existed before this and my
God she's like she's literally perfect
she's like
the the right amount of sassy and like
she's just like hey what is going on and
like I like that like Tatiana in real
life doesn't know a lot about the MCU
like us because like she's willing she
has that perspective of like all right
I'm like learning more gradually but
like it's more like a outside looking it
she she can look at like what's like the
tropes of the MCU be like why do we why
does this have to be this way or like it
just it feels like a more authentic
performance because
um you know Tatiana is new to the MCU
and like it was just really just I just
love that show but I there are a lot of
like um things that I wish sort of
and like I know that like this is the
way that I'm supposed to feel because
like she changed the ending and made her
own ending for the show but like I
really wish that like the blood thing
went went somewhere like you're it
because like I agree that it was a lot
like the super soldier serum
um because there is roots in the super
soldier Serum with Bruce's blood
um so but like I kind of like wish like
the Intelligentsia stuff was more
concrete and like yeah because like they
meant to the Intelligentsia in Avengers
2 that's already a previously
established
um entity
um associated with claw and you know I
just kind of wish that it sort of moved
those narratives along but it didn't
really do it but that's totally fine
because like you know she'll change the
ending it's just you know I there it
wasn't 100 like yeah I got what I wanted
but like it was still a fantastic show
and like I love that toxic men uh was
just so just angered by this show
because I'm just like you guys are
proving the point and um I'm glad that
like this show was able to break the
fourth wall so strongly that uh it uh it
made redditors actually mad it's pretty
crazy how like um how prophetic these
writers could be and anticipate every
argument like sure maybe they they added
some lines and posts but they added plot
points uh based off of what they
anticipated the responsibly which I just
think is pretty brilliant yo it's
[ __ ] like 5D chess bro oh for sure
all right we're halfway through our
lists I want to continue but first I
want to thank some sponsors who helped
us make this episode the second season
of the hit show DC's Batman the audio
Adventures is now on HBO Max Gotham City
a seeding cauldron of crime and
Corruption is a about to boil over in
the long shadow of two-faced and the
Penguins combined criminal might Gotham
City is gripped in Twin fists of passion
and Terror as Harley and quinzel
bulldozes a path to her heart's desire
and scarecrow floods the city with new
and improved nightmares tune in for a
tale of life and death and Gotham City
starring Jeffrey Wright Rosario Dawson
Bradley Whitford Jillian Jacobs Keenan
Thompson and Chris Parnell for him to
the channel Bobby Moynihan plays a
penguin he said in the interview with TV
Insider that it's the role he's most
proud of in his career stream DC's
Batman the audio Adventures season 2 now
on HBO Max we also want to thank Helix
sleep for sponsoring this episode sleep
is important and here at new rockstars
We Trust Helix to protect our sleep with
the best mattresses in the world I have
a helix mattress that does MT and
recently producer Zach and producer John
also got Helix mattresses Helix sleep is
a quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete and matches your body type and
your sleep preferences to the perfect
matches for you everybody's unique and
Helix knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses matches great for cooling you
down if you sleep hot mattress is great
for spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even if Helix plus
matches are inside sleepers producer
Zach took the Helix quiz and was matched
with a midnight Lux mattress because
he's a side sleeper and I needed a
softer mattress and now he doesn't wake
up with a sore shoulder or neck like he
did with the other mattresses just go to
helixsleep.com inside Marvel take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life and
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at Helix sleep.com inside
marble all right let's get back to our
rankings we are now halfway through our
lists and we are now at number four on
our list who wants to go first I can
because I already talked about it what
if dude easy easy that episode ruin me
dude I almost damn dude that doctor
strange so God damn I don't I can't get
into it just go
um a title that I'm surprised has not
come up um on our list because I thought
some of you would rank it lower my
number four is Moon Knight dude dude
wait till you get to mine okay all right
here's my thinking of moon night um I go
back and for this on this one and I
would imagine a lot of people in the
comments right now have been screaming
all episodes like why don't you rank
Moon night lower how do you think
She-Hulk and Hawkeye and Ms Marvel
whatever or or what if are worse than
Moonlight I thought Moonlight had such
high highs and I think Moon Knight ahead
the best acting performance we've seen
in any of these titles from Oscar Isaac
playing distinctly uh different
characters uh I just thought was so so
fascinating I thought this show was so
informative educational in terms of the
the nature of dissociative identity
disorder into egyptology uh I I love
that it seemed to be very sure of itself
in a way that um most other titles on
our list seem to be kind of wavering on
what story they wanted to tell I thought
they really capture this era and this
aspect of the Moon Knight character and
fitted into the MCU in a way that uh
seemed really uh
seamless and speaking of seams uh I
don't think Moon Knight has given enough
credit for having the best suit the best
fit of any of these characters the way
that uh suit uh weaves over the
character and encases him to me it's
right up there with Tony Stark first
Iron Man movie and when I was at d23 I
looked at all the costumes and I'm like
sure you know the one division costume
is pretty cool the Loki costume is
pretty cool but the Moon Knight I looked
at each one of those costumes the suit
of uh the tie the suit and then uh that
ski mask that goes over and then just
like the hooded suit with the pointed
Edge like that is so important like the
costume design is often just kind of
neglected in the MCU in a lot of these
titles but Moon Knight I think is so
authentic I thought it was so creepy and
weird and I can't wait to see more of
this in the MCU yeah it has some low
points I think a lot of the stuff with
the the other
um the any ad was uh was a little weak I
think the way that they just kind of
left Scarlett Scarab just kind of hang
in there at the end of the series I
don't I was a little bummed by because
I'm like I thought that character was so
fascinating I can't wait to see more of
but like when they go down like episode
five we explored the underworld as a
psychiatric hospital and then just going
out on the deck in the duot I thought
was some of the most gripping weird
World building I've ever seen in the MCU
and I thought it was so fascinating but
that's just me no like I I completely
agree like that's why I put Moon Knight
as my number four for uh I just feel
like it could have been I feel like it
would have been higher um if it weren't
for the the loss of um that actor
um oh yeah um because like I'm sure they
had a different story because like that
they had that whole um that whole Arc in
the in the sarcophagus with the undead
people and like there was like like
grabbed
um
the Scarlet scarabs character Layla
um I feel like there was the whole
sequence there that they uh replaced for
that um for Stephen and Layla sort of
like having that little moment with that
mummy yeah but like I I don't know I
just feel like they were just sort of
like caught up with editing because they
have to edit around his death
um but for the most part Moon Knight was
fantastic and like I I really enjoyed
um how it was just like a mystery at the
beginning like all right what's going on
and like we because we are familiar with
the character of Moon Knight we knew
that there was multiple altars and like
you know a whole thing going on there
but like even knowing that we still were
just like all right so we're introduced
with Stephen and like instead of Mark so
like where is Mark and like why is he
here and like it's just like I like a
good mystery and like it's sort of wild
I like won division a lot and like I
like I like not knowing where we're
going and I feel like Moon night and um
you know they all just handled it really
well and like
um and like fantastic choice is like I
wanted Oscar Isaac as Moon Knight for
the longest time so I'm glad that I got
that a fan cast going and um I I love
the the choice for kanchu like his
perfect voice like
commanding boys so good I mean the
design of conchu was just incredible and
creepy the way they use light uh with
that character
um Jess we're gonna let you get to Moon
Knight in a second because we know it's
higher in your list and you already
talked about what if so let's move on to
our number threes which mine is Moon
Knight yes
baby what you guys were saying was
perfect also I'm not trying to be that
person but I'm gonna be that person
Greek mythology is great I love it it's
fun we've seen so much no no I'm saying
just in general Greek mythology is great
it's fun but how much you y'all know
about Egyptian mythology how much you
guys know about these Egyptian gods how
much of how many of us were going into
Moon night being like Oh I don't even
know if I'm gonna watch it not in the
not us three but you guys in the
audience a lot of you guys are like I
don't even know who this character is
turned out to be one of the best things
to watch are you out of your mind that
show did a full 360 for people people
were not even gonna give it a chance and
then people that did watch it were like
dude this show was insane they say this
Show's sick as hell the acting was great
we learned so much about there's Gods
constantly in the MCU but we never talk
about the Indian and we never talk about
the Egyptian gods we will talk about the
eternals before we even talk about these
fellas so and this these fellas link
directly to wakanda so it's like you
guys look into this this is insane and
it's not just like a a POC driven like
great idea for uh a superhero show I
loved Moon Knight I my best friend was
like is obsessed with that this is
number one character since he was a
child he was like here's the comics you
need to read I read them I was like this
is phenomenal and then when I watched
the show I was like oh my God God so
it's number three
number three number three fair enough
fair enough that's very fair very very
fair I agree all right empty what was
your number three mind number three I'm
gonna have to say is what if and I am
disappointed then what if it's not in
your top three because like we you guys
all said that doctor strange episode was
phenomenal and yes we did the have the
party Thor episode which was like I like
very much tailored for kids it was a fun
episode but like it was like the all
right kids here's your episode like
purely for you have a fun time
um but you know I it's just that the
whole like you said that the Guardians
of the Multiverse and like being
introduced to you and like you could
tell that like the the MCU was setting
up a much bigger narrative here in what
if that we're going to see come into
fruition probably during the secret Wars
era when uh we're gonna see these
crossovers of like characters that we
never think like we there's a potential
now that um X-Men 97 could very well be
in secret Wars we can see the X-Men 97
X-Men with with all the MCU characters
because like your what ifs
um I'll now allow for your animations to
be crossed over into the MCU so like I
think the what if
um in terms of like the episodes like I
just had a good time and like not
knowing what's going to happen because
Anything could happen it's just so much
fun because like especially considering
what we do for a living of just like
analyzing uh Marvel Comics and like you
know just sort of like can being able to
predict the path with what if it's just
like all right what if I don't know uh
t'challo was the Star-Lord what what's
what's gonna happen there you you
probably wouldn't imagine that Thanos
would be in wakanda
um to being nice to everyone I didn't
see that coming uh so I I like that
value and I I hope that show never gets
canceled I hope it just keeps on going
forever because we can just have a lot
of fun with that anyway sorry you bring
up a lot of good points and T it really
that show really did open our mind to
possibilities in ways that other shows
didn't uh my number three is Miss Marvel
I'm happy I think I uh and a lot of
people are gonna say oh you're just like
flattered by Iman villani being a fan of
you uh I am yeah obviously a fan of
amount of on anything that's really cool
um but I just think the reason I rank
this show so high is like this is the
example this is the way you do it if you
want to bring in an audience to uh
sympathize and empathize and connect
with the character who they have very
very little in common with this is how
you do it you highlight an aspect of
that character that is universal and
what this character uh Kamala Khan and
this is true for her in the comics is
what G Willow Wilson did so well is
she's just what every MCU fan is she's a
fan of these Marvel heroes she wants to
be one of them she's a fan girl and
that's something we can all connect with
like I was shocked at how much I
connected with this character and it
reminded me of things that I had long
forgotten about my high school
experience uh and the fact that it
brought transported me back to high
school I was like holy crap holy crap
that idea of having parents who like
don't understand your fandom the idea
that begins with her making a YouTube
video we are all on YouTube right now
and this show got that like they were in
and that was not in the comics you know
kamalakam was not a YouTuber in the
comics they invented that and it was
such a seamless way to transition from
the rest of the MCU but into the the
world of this character uh yeah it did
have the there were some episodes of the
show where it did lose this a little bit
but I would not have thought going into
this that this show would have
everything it would have mutants it
would have the ten Rings it would have
connections to Cree technology and
setting up the MCU Cosmic uh connections
to potentially uh the dark dimension or
not the dark dimension but you know what
I mean like the the Negative Zone uh and
then have uh I wish they could have
explored more the veil yeah I want to
mention a bit more because it's one
thing that I I wish we explored more but
I just think what it did accomplish so
well and uh explain the history of the
partition weave that into her into her
Arc the fact that it connected time
travel and predestination and kind of
gave us some firm answers on how time
travel actually works in the MCU because
with the introduction of Kang really all
time travel is actually a predestined
thing it's a loop and the fact that this
show could kind of give us clarity on
questions we have from Avengers endgame
I just think it's so impressive
um so that's why I love it I probably
love it more than a lot of people do but
to me it always will have that place in
my heart it's interesting because it's
like the when we get into what if Moon
Knight Miss Marvel era and above I'm
like I could easily put Miss Marvel as
my number too I could move what if to my
number one these are all great
properties I love them so much
all great shows so we're now we all
clearly have the same
um two titles somewhere in our numbers
before we're gonna reveal that sorry
keep going one will go before the other
before we reveal that there's one other
sponsor I want to thank for helping us
make this episode I want all of us to
listen to the new audible original the
Sandman act 3. the next installment of
the number one New York Times audio best
seller based on the best-selling DC
graphic novels written by the great Neil
Gaiman adapted and directed by the
award-winning audio Master Dirk mags
James McAvoy Returns the title role of
Morpheus Lord of Dreams Stellar cast
includes Kat Dennings Kristin Shaw
Jeffrey Wright reggae Jean page and Neil
Gaiman himself new to act three are
David Harwood KJ APA and Will Wheaton in
act three we follow Morpheus on a grand
journey to take care of family business
he visits his son Orpheus an act that
comes with profound consequences
accompanied by delirium he tracks down
their estranged brother destruction the
only member of the Endless ever to
abandon their post and in the end by
seeking destruction Morpheus just might
bring those forces upon himself act 3 of
The Sandman audio epic takes us through
the fan favorite collected Volume 8
brief lives and the reality storm Tales
of Volume 7 World's End a fully
immersive listening experience presented
for the first time in breathtaking 3D
audio go deeper into the dreaming listen
now only on Audible alright we arrive at
the end of our rankings our number one
and number two obviously we have one
division we have Loki somewhere in the
title where will they end for each of us
uh who would like to begin go first and
I'm just going to talk about both of
them because it's they're both great
clearly they're great I really have no
nods but I mean peep the tattoo I'm
gonna put I'm gonna put one division is
number one no one division will be
number one also I love Scarlet Witch I
love spooky things so of course I'm
doing this I'm very stoked for Agatha
how uh coven of or is it Covenant chaos
I'm very excited for Agatha coming okay
House of the Covenant the house of Cups
house chaos coven so I'm so excited and
I I can't wait to see as we get into
more spookier things how this gets
involved evolved and same goes for Loki
I'm so excited to see how Loki gets
evolved with the TVA and Kang and
everything there so it's like two of my
favorite parts of the MCU going in two
different directions it's just which one
did I like a little bit more and to be
honest I started new rockstars really
with one division so I have to choose
one division that's my baby that's true
that's very true both different ideas
different great Creations oh
um
Mt what do you have as number one and
number two my number two
um is very much like Jessica's no no but
Loki is number two and one division as
number one and like I I really enjoyed
but like this is really hard for me
because I I
I'm very sorry I I really enjoyed Loki
because like I'm a big time travel guy I
love like you know the concept of time
travel and like I I I liked the like I
again with the I like a good mystery am
I and like Loki was like the perfect
like what is going on we our entire
knowledge of the MCU was completely
changed with Loki because like as soon
as I saw those Infinity Stones just like
chilling in a drawer I was like yes
we're in like a really like a really
different part of the MCU that like
we've never really explored and
it was just like I loved seeing um
Jonathan Majors
um just like absolutely Kick-Ass in the
final episode with his performance and
like just it was a very spooky feeling
watching Loki because the rules were
being Rewritten and like it was just
like what is going on and like seeing
the man behind the curtain of the entire
MCU you know you know barring Kevin
obviously but like the the band behind
the the the fictional curtain
um it was just so profound and so really
cool but like I really like that but
like with Wanda vision
like I'm a big fan of
pieces of media that like can speak to
people on an emotional level and on a
human level and you know given that one
division came out like during the
pandemic and like we were all sort of
just a lot of people were dealing with
loss and like you know people deal with
lots all the time but like with one
division
you know specifically being about
depression and how like you feel empty
and like you just the self-destructive
nature
um and like just having a difficulty
letting go I think that was just super
special in terms of just like
people finding comfort in that and um I
think that that's that's why I'm writing
my division so high because it's just
like it's just a really meaningful show
that was also [ __ ] amazing
um and like in this presentation and
like the music and like it just the
vision moment when Vision was um saying
say help the people while he was like
himself was disintegrating that was like
top top three MCU moments for me that's
when like that's when Vision became my
one of my top favorite Heroes because
like it was just like wow what a
selfless selfless being uh but anyway
yes
um those are my top two what about you
Eric okay
um so
um I have to diverge my number two is
one division my number one is Loki I'm
surprised but Loki is number one I I
genuinely very I was so bad yeah
um so but if you ask me any day of the
week whatever my mood is this will
change these two are almost
interchangeable for me because I agree
with everything both of you said about
one Division I think that show is a true
true work of Brilliance and I think when
it arrived in all of our lives right as
like covid started to take this new
phase where we started to get
vaccinations but we're still just like
in this drought the fact that this was
our Oasis from the Marvel drought was
just perfect like Marvel couldn't have
asked for a better show to kick off
phase four and how much of a love letter
as a kid who grew up on Nick and night
shows uh on these classic sitcoms like
grew up on Growing Pains and Full House
in the middle like those middle yeah
those middles of the season episodes uh
like I was hooked from the beginning
just with Dick Van Dyke I Love Lucy
references and bewitch references
because I did grow up watching Nick at
night episodes of that I know a lot of
people those black and white episodes it
went right over the head but for me I
was hooked and how creepy this was
whenever like you know the character
would look directly at the camera or
when uh they're like stop it stop it
stop it stop it it was like true
Twilight its own horror for me and uh
like how perfect Matt shackman
calibrated those homages to Classic
sitcoms is just great I love the the
mystery Factor Agatha all along was I
think the best needle drop we've had in
the MCU to date uh I love the character
back of the Harkness I just think a lot
of the uh I think the finale just with
the reveal of Ralph boner I think they
just just slightly slightly missed the
mark with what uh fans were hoping from
that character but that doesn't mean it
can't get fixed in a future title right
um but I love wanna Vision so much I
love what is grief if not love
persevering Loki though is my number one
because in my opinion Loki did not have
a single weak moment did not have a
single week link I love every single
character that was introduced and I was
so blown away how in those six episodes
uh they were able to keep you captivated
in the lore in the world building and
the new rules that they gave you every
single episode gave us new rules gave us
new terms gave us a new lexicon from uh
Nexus points to Nexus Nexus events
apocalyptic events uh the the way
timelines work uh like the what the
timekeepers are so that even by the end
of it when it pulls out the rug from
beneath us it doesn't negate hate
anything that came before uh and you
feel like you are attached to Loki to
where the rug keeps being pulled out
from underneath you each episode The the
settings the Landscapes the production
design of this show the performance by
Tom Hiddleston uh the character of
Sylvie and then of course the masterful
performance by Jonathan Majors is Kang
the Conqueror or he remains but a
variant of Kang like they this was the
first time in the uh on these Disney
Plus shows where we really did feel like
oh this is a major big bad in these
Disney Plus shows we actually have to
watch them Episode by episode because
these are gonna have consequences that
we're getting these rules that we've
learned are actually important to the
films did you say the fact that they
could Captivate Us I was like did you
say the performance of Richard E Grant I
didn't talk about Richard E Grant but
you're totally right he is incredible on
this series and the fact that he could
verify a fan theory that we had four
years prior on this on this channel what
uh he when he said that he was a piece
of debris floating that was a video that
I made on this channel three years early
now I'm not saying they watched their
videos
or maybe they did well maybe they did I
just think John of the Matrix is such a
good actor the fact that they could uh
Captivate Us with just a monologue from
him I think characters in rooms having
conversations is uh not always easy to
make good drama out of and the fact that
they could with this Luke finale ah I
think I think it's almost a perfect show
I think to me the Loki series the six
episodes of Loki is not only the best of
these Disney plus uh titles I think it's
better than all of the films of Marvel
phase four I put that over Spider-Man no
way home I'm sorry I just think that's
incredible that was such an incredible
master class in storytelling in my
opinion no like I really enjoyed looking
like Michael Waldron did a fantastic job
and no I'm so excited to see what he
does for Secret Wars because like I
really liked with Loki in particular
that like we're seeing sort of like his
punishment for um for his entire life of
being a shitty person especially for
um what he did in New York
um because like you know with the Loki
on the on the main timeline he sort of
like is always like getting away with it
and like you know like hahaha I'm just
like you know just being in a trickster
or whatever and he finally got his
comeuppance with uh with Thanos but like
I I just really enjoy seeing
Loki suffer because you know even though
like Loki's a great great character but
like I like seeing him like just
completely flip and be like I don't
really want a throne I just want to be
loved and to be accepted and for me to
love myself
um and so I don't think that's really
great writing anyway the end
um Loki was on a whole other level you
know what um for both of you I plan to
have a whole other segment that talked
about comparing these Marvel streaming
titles to the Marvel theatrical film
releases the black widows
we have to do that next week we can get
into it or sometime in the future we're
gonna talk about that some point in the
future maybe we do that after black
panther what kind of forever what do you
guys feel about that yeah
um I'm gonna say that right now yeah I
think I think we could already saying
bro
it's not fair to compare all the Marvel
theatrical films that they explore
because we're kind of forever we'll wait
we'll we'll put a pin in that
conversation for now
um for now we did not put uh word by
night or I am Groot in this honestly I
would put werewolf by night as number
two right after Loki where would you
guys put where we'll find out I put
werewolf by night is number
six yeah I would probably do the same
number six
just wasn't a big fan
totally okay I think you know no no no
no you wanna know everyone in that case
you know what it was it was people like
you guys that got the hype up so much
for me that when I went I was like yeah
this is good but it's not the wakanda
forever I think it lives up to our hype
I think it's as good as my head bro like
I never thought Disney would go that far
I never thought that Disney would like
be that gory in like hardcore so I was
like yo this is very sick like let's see
what is this I get that I get that for
Disney but as someone that watches gory
movies all the time I was like okay it's
not crazy
yeah but like you know just just like
that the fact that we know that the
Marvel Studios is able to go this far
with like their goal and their action
it's just like all right let's go like
Deadpool's gonna be so much less worried
about those Productions because it's
gonna be like they have all the time in
the world to make it now so we're gonna
leave it there but thank you all so much
we want to you're gonna tell us your
rankings anyway so we don't even need to
ask you but yeah let us know in the
comments below your thoughts on all of
our rankings and please know that like
your ranking is the right ranking so
like yeah
I applaud you on being so brave and
sharing your your honest thoughts on
these titles we'll leave it there for
this episode of inside Marvel follow me
at eavas follow Mt at mastertonment
subscribe to inside Marvel wherever you
get your podcast we'll see you next week
bye-bye everybody bye